[Music]
this week's 48 hours investigates the
suspicious death of amy harwick the
hollywood therapist and former fiancee
of drew carey host of the prices right
here on cbs
police found harwick unresponsive at her
home the morning after valentine's day
back in 2020 her suspected killer is
ex-boyfriend gareth pursehouse who has
been charged with her murder he has pled
not guilty drew carey spoke with 48
hours correspondent erin moriarty in his
first extensive tv interview about
harwick's death
in the hours just after valentine's day
in 2020 drew carey's former fiance amy
harwick a hollywood therapist lost her
life
obviously really beautiful
like she was smart she had a phd
master's degree she cared so much about
helping people that's that was her
life's purpose drew and amy met in 2017.
i felt so hard for her and a year later
to mark valentine's day he shared news
of their engagement my brand new lovely
fiancee amy still like many hollywood
romances theirs didn't last and they
broke up and fell out of touch and then
out of the blue just two days before her
death amy reached out i got a text from
her and would love to get together with
you and talk
and i said yeah i would love to do that
i love you are you sad you never got
that chance i never got it i never got a
chance to do it
on the last night of her life
valentine's day amy was out with friends
and took these photos not long after
police found amy lying below her bedroom
balcony fighting to breathe there were
deep marks on her neck signs that she
had been strangled inside blood on a
door and on the balcony a syringe like
this one containing a liquid that lab
tests later revealed to be nicotine
which can be a lethal poison
amy died on february 15 at 3 26 a.m
amy's friend robert koshland
i would say it was like the sun was
ripped from the sky
caution reached out to drew carey and i
just started crying you know
really bad coughlin says he instantly
knew who might have done this to amy an
ex-boyfriend gareth pursehouse whom amy
had reported for assaulting her before
they broke up in 2012.
she feared he was stalking her she
literally said if anything ever happens
to me it's gareth pursehouse's dna was
found on amy's fingernails and in her
home he was charged with her murder
purse house has pleaded not guilty
drew carey says he's grateful for that
last text exchange with amy and she did
love you because that's what i've heard
and that's the only
that's the big solace i get from it is
that she loved me and i'm glad i could
get that message to her
before she died
and aaron moriarty joins us now erin
good morning uh drew carey has not said
much about this uh why do you think he's
speaking now well i mean as you could
see even from that small piece she was
an extraordinary woman i think it's very
difficult to talk about her loss but i
think that not just drew carey but a lot
of her friends are now speaking out
because they really want to call
attention to stalking particularly
intimate partner stalking i think and
this weekend could not be a more perfect
time believe it or not valentine's day
can be a trigger and it probably was a
trigger in amy harwick's case who is
this accused murderer gareth pursehouse
well on the face of it he's a
photographer that she knew
and he's also a software engineer
but he's not just an ex-boyfriend he's
an xxx boyfriend a couple of years ago
yeah i noticed that you had talked about
that and so he is somebody that she had
not
seen
over eight years although she did think
that he might be stalking her and then
just one month before her death they had
this on you know unplanned encounter and
he suddenly starts quoting verbatim
texts she had sent him eight years
earlier so even though he says he had
nothing to do with her murder there's
evidence that he was obsessed yeah he's
accused but he has pleaded not guilty
all right aaron thank you very much it's
going to be a fascinating report you can
see aaron's full report the final hours
of amy harwick tomorrow night at 10 9
central right here on cbs and on our
streaming service paramount plus
and on the cbs news streaming network